sur le groupe Union centriste pour six
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur rapporteur cher Jean Henri
monsieur le Président de la Commission
de la culture Chalon Lafont mes chers
collègues le 3 mars 2021 il y a déjà
deux ans j'ai déposé une proposition de
loi visant à créer un ticket restaurant
étudiant je dispositif répondait une
attente importante de nombreux étudiants
notamment ceux qui se trouvaient dans
les zones blanches moins bien ou pas du
tout des servis par les dispositifs du
CROUS les zones blanches désignent des
régions où il n'y a pas de structure de
restauration universitaire à proximité
obligeant les étudiants à parcourir des
distances souvent longues pour se
restaurer un tarif abordable
face à la crise de la covid 19 qui a
gravé la précarité étudiante avec des
images bouleversantes de jeunes faisant
la queue lors de distribution
alimentaire caritative cette proposition
de loi consignée par 82 sénateurs de
trois groupes politiques différents
visés apporter une solution concrète et
rapide un problème réel
la pandémie accentué les inégalités
sociales et a rendu les conditions de
vie des étudiants encore plus difficiles
notamment en termes de logements
d'accéder à l'éducation et de santé
mentale
je tiens à remercier mes collègues de
news centrices qui ont accepté
d'inscrire cette proposition de loi dans
notre niche parlementaire de ce jour oui
mes chers collègues nous avons progressé
nous sommes proches de notre objectif
créer un dispositif permettant un prêt
de 500 000 étudiants d'avoir accès à une
restauration à tarif modéré comme si le
cas dans les grands centres
universitaires
l'accès à une alimentation saine et
abordable est essentielle pour le
bien-être et la réussite académique des
étudiants je crois que nous sommes tous
d'accord sur ce principe
lors de l'examen par l'Assemblée
nationale le texte a évolué l'ancienne
majorité et le gouvernement n'ont pas
souhaité conserver le dispositif initial
préférent miser sur le repas 1 € une
mesure loi en soi cette mesure bien que
bénéfique pour les étudiants ayant accès
à un restaurant universitaire ne
répondez pas à la problématique des
zones blanches
les étudiants sans accès à un restaurant
du CROUS ne pouvait de toute façon pas
profiter des repas 1 euro les laissant
dans une situation extrêmement précaire
j'interpellé à plusieurs reprises un
ancienne ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche sur ce
sujet on lui demandant de trouver des
solutions malheureusement sans succès je
salue par contre l'action volontaire de
Sylvie Retailleau sa successeur et notre
dialogue commun pour chercher et trouver
des solutions
la collaboration entre les différentes
instances politiques est essentielles
pour résoudre les dix problèmes auxquels
sont confrontés les étudiants
aujourd'hui le texte que nous examinons
est différent au fil de nos travaux en
commission et la navette parlementaire
cette proposition de loi évoluée
certains pourraient penser qu'elle ne va
passer loin ou que le dispositif initial
et des natures
je trouvais à titre personnel assez
simple et facile à mettre en œuvre une
proposition de création d'un ticket
restaurant étudiant
mais mes chers collègues je crois qu'il
faut savoir penser à l'intérêt de nos
étudiants et d'éviter une nouvelle
navette vers l'Assemblée nationale si
nous nous votions pas ce texte conforme
il faut se satisfaire de victoire quelle
qu'elle soit lorsque nous en avons
l'occasion le compromis atteint
apportera des améliorations
significatives à la situation des
étudiants en difficulté
notre objectif est bien n'est-ce pas
d'améliorer la vie des étudiants qui
c'est compliqué depuis la crise de la
covid-19 et maintenant la crise de
l'inflation
une partie des critiques émise par
certaines collègues de nos groupes des
groupes politiques résidaient dans le
risque qu'il percevait d'affaiblissement
des CROUS avec la mise en place du
ticket restaurant étudiant ils craignait
que l'instauration de ce dispositif ne
détournent les étudiants des structures
existantes et n'entraîne à terme une
diminution des ressources pour les CROUS
bien que je ne partage pas t'inquiétude
qu'il soit rassuré le dispositif actuel
sera organisé autour des CROUS via des
conventions avec des structures de
restauration qu'elles soient publiques
comme les cuisines centrales de mairie
de l'hôpital par exemple ou privé comme
des restaurants ou des restaurants
d'entreprises
ce partenariat permettra de soutenir les
CROUS tout en offrant des alternatives
pour les étudiants dans les zones
blanches et s'il n'y a pas de
possibilités de conventionner et bien
les étudiants pourront éventuellement se
voir verser une aide financière pour se
restaurer c'est un des dispositifs
prévus par cette proposition de loi
cette mesure permettra jusqu'à 500 000
étudiants de bénéficier d'un tarif
modéré pour pouvoir manger l'essentiel
c'est bien cela
nous ne pouvons pas dire que cette
mesure coûte cher car il s'agit ni plus
ni moins que du rétablissement d'une
égalité sur un droit existant mais
simplement non exercé en raison de
l'absence de restaurant universitaire
j'espère que le Sénat votera très
largement en faveur de cette proposition
de loi il adoptera conforme
la prochaine étape sera sa promulgation
rapide et d'écriture des décrets
d'application j'ai bien noté madame la
ministre votre volonté de nous associer
à cette écriture je vous en remercie
très sincèrement avant de conclure je
tiens à remercier tout particulièrement
mon collègue et pour son application sur
cette proposition de loi et bien
évidemment Laurent Lafont président de
la commission Culture pour son aide et
c'est précieux conseils et enfin cela
ira faire administratrice pour la
qualité de son travail les chers
collègues vous l'aurez compris le groupe
de l'Union centriste votre unanimement
en faveur de cette proposition de loi il
est étant d'agir pour soutenir nos
étudiants et leur offrir enfin des
conditions de vie plus décentes ce texte
est une première étape il y a encore
beaucoup à faire pour que nos chers
étudiants n'aient qu'un seul objectif se
concentrer et réussir leurs études ils
peuvent compter sur mon engagement le
plus total je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Esther pour 3 minutes